Game of Thrones fans can and will find
plenty of reasons to feel outraged over
an episodes embrace of darkness viewers
kicked screamed cried and begged for
comfort after watching the rains of
castamere episode from season 3
better known as the installment
featuring the red wedding audiences once
again felt their stomachs churn when
Prince Oberyn Martell got his brains
bashed in during season fours that
mountain and the Viper and felt a
similar feeling of dread when Shireen
Baratheon was burned alive on the season
5 episode the dance of dragons while
watching the third episode of season 8
titled the long night fans took to
social media to air their latest
grievances about the show
now while the practice of criticizing on
Twitter is nothing new for the Game of
Thrones fandom the April 28th episode
elicited a rather unique highly specific
complaint according to fans the episode
was just too dark in the most literal
way not long after the long night began
Twitter exploded with complaints about
how dark the much-anticipated battle
sequence was for many the episode was
nearly unwatchable because the lighting
was so dense
variety writer Carol and diaphragm cut
tweeted mid episode sure we can't see
anything on Game of Thrones without
squinting but the thing is it's dark at
night and the ice dragons show is
extremely committed to realism news
reporter Courtney Theriot has the
perfect response to the frustrating
darkness tweeting after watching Battle
of Winterfell I honestly don't know if
I'll ever be able to look at a sunny sky
again without going blind one user
posted an impassioned tweet asking
television executives to think of the
audience before deciding how to light
each episode writing dear people making
TV shows the viewers at home would
prefer if they could see what was
happening on screen stop making
everything so dark
sincerely everyone watching tonight's
Game of Thrones another Twitter user
also expressed increasing frustration
over not being able to fully see
everything that was going down during
the Battle of Winterfell tweeting no
clue what's happening in Game of Thrones
because it's too dark I have adjusted
the settings on my TV and it still
didn't help guess I will be reading show
summaries tomorrow bright and early
another fan took direct aim at HBO
slamming the network for spending
enormous amounts of money on episodes
where viewers have little idea what's
unfolding due to how dark it is HBO
let's make a show about dragons and
zombies and spend a gazillion dollars on
it also HBO let's make it so dark
literally no one can tell what's
happening fortunately not every Game of
Thrones fan took issue with the lighting
choice many viewers started firing back
on Twitter at those bashing the episode
arguing that no one should have been
surprised by the lack of light after all
the episode was literally titled the
long night and as we know night em has
historically been pretty dark Game of
Thrones has been visually dark since day
one it's funny that people are upset now
like it's new I figured last night was
shot the way that it was to add to the
chaos for the viewer the characters
didn't know what was going on at either
did we another user wrote stop barking
that it was too dark you better buy some
high quality TV or should have watched
it on HD you fools it was meant to be
dark cinematography because it happened
during dark winter the characters also
had a hard time seeing so it was
actually immersive Screen Rant features
editor Hannah Shaw Williams had perhaps
the most level-headed reaction to the
criticism according to her those who
found fault with the long night for
being incredibly dark are entitled to
their opinion and those who had no
trouble making out everything that
happened shouldn't shout down those who
didn't have the same experience the
editor tweeted like do I need to get out
the histograms to prove how insanely
underlit the show is I feel like this is
some kind of weird mask gas lighting
campaign by the way if you are gas
lighting please send your gas lights to
HBO because they clearly need them
overall the long night was a pretty epic
episode despite some major events being
difficult to see Melisandre return to
Winterfell and ignited the Dothraki
swept ins with fire courtesy of the Lord
of Light the dead rose in the crypts of
Winterfell
Theon Greyjoy heroically sacrificed his
life to try and defend bran Stark a few
major characters died during the battle
and Arya Stark went full prince that was
promised by killing the night king with
her dagger made of Valyrian steel
after all she knows the true secrets of
combat sticking with a pointy head at
the end of the day when you play the
game of Thrones you either win or you
die and when you watch Game of Thrones
you either invest in some night-vision
goggles to see what's happening or you
strain your eyes trying check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about Game of Thrones
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]